hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play Spectre I saw
that yamimash play this and it looked
like an interesting game I didn't see
too much of his video because I wanted
some of it to be a surprise but from
what I saw it seemed to be pretty
interesting so let's give it a try oh
yeah I shamelessly stole that from
yamimash
okay here we go how to play crack the
code code cracking window can be
accessed with the C key once you have
opened it you will see a text field oh
God
no penalties for incorrect guesses notes
littered around the map read the notes
let's see the monster can only move when
you're not looking at it but if you look
at it too long it will do unpredictable
things game over in the monster is too
close okay so basically Slender
mechanics okay cool
so this is in project from what I saw on
the UM this sound from what I saw on the
website what is that
was that it's really
whoa where'd it go it's really dark like
really dark there's nothing for my
flashlight to reflect off of okay so
this seems kind of like slender but all
right I'm already getting creeped out I
don't know what I saw at the bottom of
the hill look like the a bust of a
statue or something what is that what is
that sound
okay it's just tree I think that's like
pointing at anything okay looks like
quite a bit of work it's been put into
this all these trees look different and
it's made on the unity engine as far as
I can tell other than that I can't
really tell you much about the game
other than it's really freakin dark okay
I'm hearing that sound I don't know I
know what's going on okay oh that body's
my sprint meter I'm about to run out of
batteries Oh who's a fire I thought it
sounded like a fire oh it's couple fires
is that a trailer some I see like a big
thing hanging overhead I'm not sure what
that is happen either way I'm looking
for notes because I need to I need to
know oh god what have I done how do I
get out of you oh god no okay there we
go
I so I'm following these torches down a
valley that's going deeper and deeper I
don't see a monster just yet but I'm
sure he'll make his appearance if I turn
off my flashlight do my batteries
recuperate
no they don't well what am I supposed to
do it's dark okay what is that thing is
that a bridge or just a big tree that
fell down okay I'm walking into a circle
of something as creepy what is that no
it's a square sorry I thought it was a
circle what the hell is this can I jump
barely I can jump like like an inch off
the ground my legs are so weak okay I
don't know what this is but it's
directly below that thing whatever that
is I'm not exactly sure what's going on
here man this is so weird I don't really
know what to say about I mean it looks
great a lot of a lot of work has been
put into this but you know it's kind of
bleeding off the old you know Slenderman
feel of games alright I'm getting out of
here that might be like that worries me
whenever that body goes all red after
I'm done sprinting but anyway
it kind of rubbing off on the Slenderman
vibe like a lot of games have I mean the
idea of collecting notes is kind of
similar but I like the idea that it's a
different objective you don't need to
collect all the notes to just collect
them you need to collect it for a goal
and that's nice but other than that
let's see if we can try to find the
monster
that lurks in the darkness oh I could oh
I thought I could climb like the
vertical face of the hill right there
damn it let me out of here I need to get
out there's got to be other stuff that I
need to find and it is dark and I'm
about to run out of batteries
what am I gonna do when I run out of
batteries I can't adjust my brightness
like in um haunt I'm gonna be boned in
just a few seconds and you guys aren't
even gonna be able to see anything this
seems to be a problem I knew you well
still want to know that statue is all
about what said ah this looks like a
little sum oh it is a bridge okay so
there is a giant-ass bridge that is
bridging the gap between the two sides
of this valley okay I'm officially out
of batteries and I don't think that I'll
be recharging anytime soon all right so
we got a bridge and nothing else
ah what what am I looking at I'm looking
at it
what am I looking at I didn't see a damn
thing but its sides are like a little
red dot in the distance I thought it was
a fire was I looking at a monster
okay that's the way I came I came from
outside of the valley and why can't I
see the flames in the distance it's not
working to my advantage I am way out of
flashlight battery man that is a quick
flashlight ah known nnnnno no you can't
do that to me
can't do that to me I see something on
the ground over there what is that
please tell me it's batteries and it is
okay it was half the batteries that I
need to survive what is happening
why
I didn't see a monster did you what the
heck
please let me see what's killing me
before it rips my lungs out man okay all
right let's try this again
I'll read the how to play first I
already read the how do I play okay
let's try that again let's go straight
for the bridge I'm gonna listen to the
UM I think as you a fire right there so
I go that way and whatever that that's
stop knock on anywhere near that statue
if that was the monster oh that's a
house oh I probably should have come
here first I'm dumb I'm a mareun I'm a
stupid oh it looks good let's see just
born if laughs does God know I just saw
in the demon
all right good for me we got here Oh an
axe that looks good just there looks
like some ah notes across the bridge and
up the hill a statue you will find
oh wait a minute that's a Slenderman oh
okay there was a path that I should have
followed and I went wandering into the
wilderness huh - - nothing I I've failed
on that regard I'm sorry everybody I am
stupid for some reason I went towards
the Statue and I don't even know what
statue that was or what it was what to
do I I'm turning out my flashlight as
I'm following the trail ah man sorry if
I seem tired or low-energy guys it's
been a it's been a long few days I've
been really really ridiculously busy I
even know why I need these batteries
right now but I'll pick them up anyway
it's been a very very busy few days and
I have not been getting enough sleep but
that's no fault of yours and I need not
trouble you with my problems flashlight
back on let's see what we can find
man this guy can't jump for anything
can't sprint at all what a wimp at least
you could jog this is like the slowest
what that's a statue that is the thing
that's it how's it is that the monster
I'm looking right at it huh and now it's
gone is that the statue I was supposed
to find before okay that's what the note
said that I would find a statue okay let
me go towards that one there
got it cannot see a thing in this forest
shad the flashlight isn't even helping
they're barely at all I'm probably gonna
have to brighten this up in post again
like some other games I got I got a bad
feeling about this because when I was
right around here huh come on there's
got to be another torch up this hill
maybe aha
I see your smoke okay so I mean there's
got to be something else here but
there's something lurking in the
darkness right behind you don't turn
around it's still there okay huh oh
there's a statue again what's with the
statue
how the statue goes away good for it
lead me to where I need to go oh wait no
that's what it's doing oh okay
yeah I don't even know what what I'm
talking about half of the time I don't
even know what I'm saying half the time
that I'm playing these games what am I
doing with my life what am i doing why
am I in these woods what did I just hear
oh okay I heard another crackle man
these things are getting harder to find
my leg cuz that's not doing anything oh
good they're batteries at the base of
that torch at least that's a little
something
I think I hear a flame yeah I see you
flame just up that hill I think maybe ah
that's much better
ah there it is okay now if I only could
find what you're leading me to if you
could tell me what my great purpose of
being here I don't even know how I got
here
like what core what sort of crazy
cryptographer is this taking like a
cancer is coud I think I'll take a walk
deep into the forest where no one will
find me except the monsters the monsters
will find me I don't know I don't know I
don't know I don't know
damn on top of high me yeah it's a
monster behind you okay don't do that
that is - dick thing to do don't be
making noises when they're not gonna do
anything that's way over there it's so
far away and I'm so out of shape
ah duh I'm as a Clark no I'm not duh
okay alright
ah
okay uh I don't know okay I don't know
or I don't know and the game actually
crashed on me again so I'm [ __ ] I'm I
don't even know I don't even know I I
mean I can't I can't say that I solved
it so I'm gonna leave it this one up to
you guys you guys um play the game for
yourselves tell me how what I'm doing
wrong because I must be doing something
wrong because it's like that jump scare
appears with the monster and then
instantaneously there's nothing I can
really do unless I needed to like turn
around and run the opposite direction
right away I don't really know but you
guys need tell me what to do if you guys
can find an end to this game let me know
in the comments below other than that
thank you guys so much for watching
click the annotation for more video set
I've done and as always I will see you
in the next video bye bye
not even a little bit sorry that's how
they got past us last time
actually every time they fell over the
side before I just want it I got point
set it and forget it